[Música]
volvemos con ustedes para una nueva
entrevista en cinco minutos con jason
klein mit de politólogo alemán buen día
profesor y se va a angela merkel de la
dirección de alemania después de 13 años
al frente del proyecto europeo
hoy en día ella es considerada una de
las últimas columnas por la estabilidad
de la unión europea que sigue para el
bloque sin el protagonismo de merkel
buenos días gracias por la invitación si
es correcto y con la invitación que con
la elección de amina ser básicamente uno
podría decir que en su partido ha
elegido la continuidad
pero ahí sigue todavía un conflicto un
conflicto esencialmente entre dos lados
del mismo partido y el competidor de la
fed ha ganado 385 votos en el primer
turno así que ahí sigue una cierta
división entre los dos lados que puede
causar más
pues más división y más descenso en la
política del partido mayor de alemania
en el momento de las elecciones más
adelante vamos a hablar de eso pero
antes de la crisis de los migrantes
causó en 2013 un punto de inflexión en
el mandato de merkel se equivocó la
líder con su política de acogida no en
realidad no en realidad los datos los
diferentes datos sobre la población
migrante son positivas y en realidad hoy
en día ya no es un punto tan
controversial como lo era en 2015 y
después durante más o menos dos años y
hoy en día con la pandemia uno podría
decir que el tema está ausente los
inmigrantes y refugiados están y están
integrándose al mercado laboral en
grandes números así que aún
en realidad ya no es la controversia de
entonces pero hoy en día son otros temas
como cómo tratar con la pandemia cómo
seguir con las relaciones con rusia y
con eeuu ahora con la nueva presidencia
de joe biden cómo seguir con la política
energética que ha sido un gran tema y
son básicamente esos temas que hoy día
predominan en el ámbito político alemán
bueno hace un minuto nos hablaba de cómo
puede haber divisiones aún en el partido
hace bien a angela merkel en retirarse
especialmente en un momento en el que
los nacionalismos se fortalecen tanto en
alemania como en otros países de europa
en realidad el nacionalismo de derecha
ha estancado sobre todo después de la
pandemia cuando muchos votantes ya no
vieron la inmigración como un problema
mayor y también posiblemente por el
break shit que hizo justamente en las
últimas semanas hizo obvio cuando cuán
grandes pueden ser los daños económicos
por el nacionalismo así que hay en
realidad tal vez ha escogido bien el
momento cuando pues obviamente los
críticos si están obviamente el debate
sí sí existe como es normal en una
democracia pero ya no estamos viendo a
un pues animosidad es tan importantes
como lo era en 2017
en las encuestas los nacionalistas de
derecha tienen menos que 10 por ciento
después de ganar casi 13% en los
comicios de 2017 así que posiblemente es
un momento oportuno bueno y para
finalizar viene armen la sed como
líderes del cdu que le espera al partido
muy rápidamente
uno podría decir superficialmente que es
una persona que va a continuar más o
menos el estilo de angela merkel de
todas formas no es un mini merkel no no
no fue criado políticamente por angela
merkel pero por aún sectores católicos
del cdu en westfalia renania del norte
el mayor estado de alemania y aún tiene
entonces su propia base de poder han
trabajado en diferentes campos de la
política política exterior política está
dual y va a poner sus propios acentos en
la política alemana muchas gracias a
ustedes y son los matices de la salida
del poder de la mujer más poderosa del
mundo sigan con nosotros en france 24
[Música]